علينا أن نفصل
بين وسائل الإعلام في إسرائيل ووسائل
الإعلام الدولية. أعتقد أن
وسائل الإعلام الدولية بشكل عام
تلعب دورًا عادلاً للغاية وهو جلب
الصور من غزة إلى كل منزل في
أوروبا وفي آسيا وأفريقيا، ويجب على الجميع
رؤية ما يحدث.  في غزة الآن، أصبح من
واجب كل مواطن في العالم تقريبًا
أن يرى الأطفال الجرحى، وأن يرى
المشردين، وأن يرى الجثث، وأن
يرى المستشفيات التي يجب على الجميع رؤيتها،
ووسائل الإعلام تقوم بعملها من خلال
إظهار ذلك بما أستطيع.  لا أقول عن
وسائل الإعلام الإسرائيلية التي تخفي ذلك
بشكل منهجي ومتعمد
وطوعي عن المشاهدين والقراء الإسرائيليين،
الإسرائيليون لا يرون شيئًا لأنهم
لا يريدون رؤية أي شيء، أعتقد أنه
يجب أن يكون هناك حريق في رابطة الدول المستقلة في الحال،
يجب أن يكون هناك نوع من النار  دخول القوة الدولية
إلى غزة
لفترة من الوقت على الأقل، وقبل كل شيء،
يجب أن ينتهي الحصار المفروض على غزة،
هذا هو المشهد الأول ويجب أن يأتي هذا، من
المستحيل إبقاء 2.3 مليون شخص في
قفص لمدة 16 عامًا الآن، يجب أن ينتهي هذا